[Music]
on this Friday night the different
response to two nautical tragedies
theirs wasn't a once in a lifetime
Voyage but they're one shot at a better
life we can do things a different way
the calls for a quicker response as
questions Mount over the submersible
lost at sea the NHL is moving backwards
the NHL on thin ice as onlookers react
to a jersey Banning Fiasco Ukrainian
superhumans how life-saving Prosthetics
are helping build a better tomorrow in
the war-torn nation we are building the
future culture right here right now plus
parliament's massive overhaul a look
inside Canada's largest ever heritage
project and its multi-billion dollar
price tag
global national with para Nasser good
evening and thanks for joining us we're
learning more tonight about the
experimental and ultimately flawed
design of a submersible that imploded at
the Titanic wreck site the wreckage and
the five people who died now rest at Sea
not far from the Titanic but just a week
earlier there was another nautical
disaster off the coast of Greece that
devastated many more families at least
700 migrants died when they are ship
capsized and it's a dangerous route
according to the United Nations 160 000
people risked it all to cross the
Mediterranean to Europe last year alone
close to 2500 others they didn't make it
the unequal level of attention and
urgency surrounding these disasters
hasn't gone unnoticed and as Nita garcha
reports it'll take a global effort to
change
a pregnant woman died trying to reach
the Canary Islands on Tuesday her body
found in a boat with more than 50
migrants the rest survived the journey
unlike hundreds who were fear dead off
the coast of Greece when this crowded
fishing boat sank last week it was one
of the mediterranean's deadliest migrant
shipwrecks in years a story swept from
the spotlight it's even more than
indifference I mean it's shocking song
fraud I mean to be able to close your
eyes to the situation of what's
happening in the Mediterranean their
plight overshadowed by the race to find
five people on the Titan submersible
that government slept in so quickly
University of Toronto Professor Joan
samalcik says this needs to be a wake-up
call for lawmakers in Western Nations
who create policy around selling arms
for war and don't seem to see the
connection to the plight of refugees
affected by those Wars and in my long
history of working with refugees I have
never met one who wanted to leave their
home
it was really a push out out of
desperation the response to the the
submarine should show us that you know
we we can come together with a huge
International no expenses spared rescue
operation
um for five people lost in the Atlantic
at least 350 pakistanis were on the
capsized boat off Greece
DNA samples of more than 200 families
have been collected to try and identify
victims I've been working in Greece five
years I was myself in the sea rescuing
people
and I've seen with my own eyes how the
Greek Coast Guard is treating the rich
refugees humanitarian Salem Aldine
questions why Greek authorities didn't
immediately intervene given how
overcrowded and unseaworthy the vessel
was there is waves which is not just
that you can tow a boat like that
without knowing there is a huge risk
that something can happen
Advocates say this should be a moment of
accountability and action we can do
things a different way it is not
inevitable that so many people should
run especially in light of reports the
U.S Navy detected a catastrophic
implosion days earlier yet more
International resources were deployed to
assist in the search and no end in sight
to the migrant and Refugee crisis
Global News
hundreds of migrants near the Canary
Islands are recovering after being
rescued off the coast of West Africa 227
people need emergency help yesterday on
route to Spain for boats have required
rescue in the region in the past 48
hours and summer is the busiest time of
year for attempted Crossings the Canary
Islands have become the main starting
point for migrants trying to reach Spain
Canadian vessels are returning home
after searching for that lost
submersible off Newfoundland multiple
agencies from Canada and the U.S are
investigating but it's complicated and
tonight there are new questions around
the vessel's structural engineering Mike
Armstrong joins us now from St John's
Mike Gates becoming clear that some of
the warnings were ignored
well Farrah think about this the Titan
was officially experimental it wasn't
certified that means Ocean Gate couldn't
even dive with it legally here in the
harbor in St John's they had to take it
out into international waters so Ocean
Gate shouldn't have been doing what it
was doing I think that's pretty clear
one of the people now speaking out is
James Cameron the director of the
Titanic movie has made 33 Dives to the
wreck he also built his own submarine
Cameron says he didn't believe in The
Titan's carbon fiber Hull and regrets
not speaking out earlier it's the Ocean
Gate Titanic experience look we
celebrate Innovation right but you
shouldn't be using experimental vehicle
for for paying passengers
the search continues at the site the U.S
Coast Guard says it's mapping the two
debris Fields found on the ocean floor
there may now be overlapping
investigations Canada's Transportation
safety board confirmed Friday it is
investigating the Titan tragedy also
Global News has learned that TSB is in
negotiations with the U.S Transportation
safety board and the U.S Coast Guard
over roles and responsibilities in terms
of jurisdiction it is complicated The
Vessel was lost about 680 kilometers
from St John's in international waters
the victims were from four different
countries Pakistan the U.S France and
the UK and the ship that launched the
Titan the polar Prince is Canadian add
to that the fact something like this
tragedy isn't covered by the United
Nations law of the Seas it covers things
like extraction of minerals from the
seabed and fishing but doesn't really
cover things like submersicals treat it
like a crime scene oceanographer David
Gallo hopes there are answers that lead
to safer Vehicles This Disaster is the
first implosion of a submersible with
passengers on board he says it's
something the community has feared but
expected we knew that we were lucky to
go this long with man submersibles and
not have that kind of an accident and
yet when it happened we were all stunned
like it had you know it happened
now TSB investigators are on their way
here to St John's as is the ship that
launched the Titan Sunday the polar
Prince is expected here in the harbor
early Saturday morning Farah
like Armstrong and St John's thanks Mike
the Royal Canadian Air Force has
released the names of the two pilots
killed in that helicopter crash this
week
the Chinook crashed into the Ottawa
River in Petawawa Ontario shortly after
midnight on Tuesday the bodies of two
pilots were recovered and have now been
identified as 32-year-old Captain David
domagala and 53-year-old Captain Mark
larouche two crew members survived and
they were treated in hospital for minor
injuries and have been released
the premiere of New Brunswick is facing
a growing caucus Revolt that could cost
him his job and even possibly plunge the
province into a snap election
today a longtime Progressive
conservative party loyalist became the
second MLA to quit Blaine Higgs cabinet
as David Aiken reports that resignation
could be the most serious challenge yet
to higgs's leadership
long way in terms of Trevor holder is
the longest serving member of New
Brunswick's legislature he's won his St
John area riding seven times and served
in the cabinets of three different
Progressive conservative premiers but
today he said he'd had enough of Blaine
Higgs under the leadership of Premier
Higgs holder wrote caucus has been less
about consensus and more about him
getting his own way his lack of empathy
as well as his inability to listen
demonstrates a further inability to lead
the citizens of New Brunswick holder is
the second cabinet minister to quit in
the last two weeks and his resignation
came hours after a group of PC riding
Association presidents released a letter
saying the Grassroots of the party
wanted Higgs to go see certainly not
communicating with the general
population of the VC party of New
Brunswick and I think that's upset a lot
of people
crisis was sparked over what is known as
policy 713 that's a policy designed to
protect lgbtq two plus students Higgs
changed that rule to require that
teachers must inform parents about a
student who changes names or pronouns
lgbtq2 plus Advocates said that move
could endanger some students but that
controversy quickly morphed into a
challenge of Higgs overall leadership
style it's not just one issue I've said
that repeatedly
um you know I'm finding that the party's
drifting away from my values and the PC
party that I grew up with was was a
team-based approach the core criticism a
premier who is high-handed imperious and
aloof Blaine Higgs is a very competent
man he is a very decisive man
but he's had some missteps in the last
couple of months the presidents of more
than half of the province's PC riding
associations are now calling on the
party's governing Council to call a
formal leadership review it is odd to
launch a leadership review of a sitting
Premier that is that tells you something
that tells you there's a lot of
disaffection pigs has been New
Brunswick's Premier since 2018 and he
says he has every intention of holding
on to that job David Akin Global News
political divisions are also driving
controversy in the hockey world the NHL
announced as of next season's special
jerseys will no longer be worn by
players during warm-up the custom
uniforms allow teams to Mark special
events and important causes including
Pride celebrations as Jackson prosco
explains many fear this move signals the
league is giving in to Rising hostility
against gay and trans communities
NHL players wear warm-up jerseys to
honor the military for cancer awareness
and for Lunar New Year there are jerseys
celebrating indigenous culture and
Jersey celebrating the lgbtq plus
Community but no more the way the league
puts it is that it became such a
distraction that arose to such a level
of taking away from like the the product
on the ice though they decided not to
use any specialty jerseys in warm-ups
the League's decision to bench all
cause-based jerseys is because of one
cause Pride my choice is to stay true to
myself and my religion this past season
several players refused to Don Pride
uniforms which quickly spiraled into
controversy and so the league has called
a time out this is a league that's
terrified of winding up on Fox News it's
terrified of a Bud Light like boycott
it's terrified that they might alienate
that kind of portion of Their audience
bigger as it might be it's unfortunate
that in this day and age that we are
getting that sort of reaction it's
dismaying to those who've worked to
increase lgbtq plus participation in
sport
it comes at a worrying time as major
corporations in the U.S and Canada face
backlash for acknowledging pride month
well over 95 percent of the players who
proudly donned those Pride jerseys for
pre-game warm-ups uh were able to use
their uh visibility to help the
community though NHL commissioner Gary
Bettman says Pride nights and other
specialty nights will continue players
can now only model specialty jerseys so
long as they're not on the ice the
Junior League Oshawa Generals believe
the big league has it all wrong it's a
stepping stone of growing with the
community and now the NHL is moving
backwards after years of promoting
hockey for everyone the NHL finds itself
at the center of the very controversy it
was trying to avoid as its rinks get
dragged into the political Arena
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
the ukrainians Turning tragedy into
Triumph coming up an inside look at the
organization helping War victims become
superhumans plus historic highs in
Beijing Millions sweltering and
record-breaking temperatures in China's
capital
in Ukraine Russia's war is ravaging not
only property but people drones missile
attacks mines and combat situations are
leading to countless ukrainians losing
limbs that's where an organization
called superhumans comes in it has a
goal of creating a new culture not of
acceptance but of Pride it's ensuring
amputees are set up to live full lives
where they're envied for their bionic
Parts Crystal gemancing and video
journalist Bradham Latin were invited to
the superhumans facility in leviv to see
the Transformations firsthand
so far so far walking onto the grounds
of the Superhuman Center you're struck
by a wave of ambition courage and
camaraderie
Sergey kopashak is teased by the CEO of
the organization she tells him now that
he's mastered the stairs they should
discharge him he retort saying as much
as he likes it here he'll have to leave
sometime Sergey is amazing because he
was the one who was very quick to
rehabilitate and like he started walking
on like for a day the superhuman's
philosophy is not about what's been lost
but what's been added
I've been on my prosthetic for a month
now he says he admits it wasn't easy
they're not his legs but he's mastering
them and he's decorated them hoper
shook's left leg was torn off the right
one badly damaged during shelling the 25
year old Soldier smiles when he talks
about being upgraded to a cyborg those
admitted to the Superhuman Center are
initially seen by a fellow amputee the
team is explicit in its belief that
abled body people cannot grasp the loss
or the lifelong pain and struggle of
having a prosthetic which will always
require adjustments but they can help to
reshape how Society views them we
believe that if we have superhumans on
the streets of Ukraine it's going to be
different trajectory for the country and
if our kids are raised in the context of
superhumans not in the context of
victims of war we're going to have a
different country
some prosthetic pieces are made locally
at the Superhuman Center other
components are sourced from
manufacturers until the work can be done
in-house they're also building temporary
living space next door and want to add a
surgical Ward and hire their own medical
staff this facility really is meant to
be a One-Stop shop from manufacturing
downstairs to the rehabilitation in the
floor and up here people are doing
everything from exercises to even having
their Prosthetics adjusted to make
walking a little bit easier ultimately
they want to see five of these
facilities right across Ukraine
many people have complications and have
to start over as I did after surgery
says yuvhen who only gave us his first
name he just recently started to receive
Care at the Superhuman Center he says
it's more Progressive more prepared to
help people like him the facility has
some big backers including American
Howard Buffett son of Warren Buffett
who's donated more than 16 million
dollars to superhumans and just recently
visited the facility the estimated
operating cost is about one million
dollars per month Olga rudnova believes
when people see what they're doing and
why they're doing it more Partners will
come on board we are building the future
culture right here right now with these
amazing people who gave their health and
parts of their body for the victory
looking ahead to the future is
motivation for Sergey
I have a son in two months and my dream
is to meet my wife from the maternity
hospital standing on my own two feet a
dream that's getting closer step by step
day by day Crystal gomancing Global News
live Ukraine
[Music]
bracing for Brett had concerns about
flash floods as the tropical storm hits
the Eastern Caribbean
[Music]
rough weather is slamming the Caribbean
tropical storm Brett bringing winds more
than 100 kilometers an hour and up to 25
centimeters of rain in some areas there
are concerns flash floods and Storm
surges could get worse Brett is expected
to dissipate on Sunday but another storm
Cindy has formed behind it it's the
first time two storms have formed in the
tropical Atlantic in June
Beijing is experiencing a prolonged Heat
Wave the city recording its hottest June
Day Ever the temperature climbed to 41.1
degrees on Thursday the highest since
record keeping began more than 60 years
ago and that's about 10 degrees above
the normal high temperatures the heat
prompted officials to upgrade its
warning system to Red alerting people
temperatures above 40 degrees will
continue for several days China's broken
many heat records this year including in
Shanghai which recorded its hottest May
Day in more than a century
[Music]
Canada's largest Fixer-Upper next a look
at the multi-billion dollar renovations
to Parliament Hill
[Music]
tonight we have an inside look at the
largest heritage project in Canadian
history the major renovations to
Parliament Hills center block more than
450 construction workers are wrapping up
the first phase of the multi-billion
dollar upgrades to the historic building
a Monumental task that began four years
ago and is expected to take another
decade to complete tariya isri takes us
on a tour
the peace tower has watched over
Parliament Hill for almost a century now
it's getting the view of center block
below the surface the Heritage building
is being stripped down to the bone to
modernize one of Canada's most storied
symbols we faced our a number of
challenges but the project remains on
track the pandemic
the trucker Convoy and a public Sector
Strike
but things are moving along the earliest
completion date is slated for 2032. the
government insists the 4.5 billion
Renault is on budget and worth the
massive price tag it is a I think of
tremendous value to have both to keep
hold of our country's Traditions but
also to build forward they're building
forward by digging a pit 23 meters deep
removing thousands of truckloads of
bedrock
part of a delicate operation to lift
center block off its concrete foundation
for a seismic upgrade to make it better
withstand the next earthquake you can
see the the crumbling mortar damaged
sculptures old pipes it's taking an army
just to bring center block up to code
this is the House of Commons when it was
built a century ago there were 230 MPS
since then that number has grown
significantly and the members of
parliament need extra space
the now unrecognizable house is being
reconfigured to be more accessible and
more spacious for the 343 MPS coming
back here they moved out in 2018 to
their Temporary Home the West block this
is the Pei window so 20 000 Heritage
items have been removed for restoration
including light fixtures from the Hall
of Honor blackened from the days you
could smoke inside Parliament a new
Welcome Center will be the Public's
front door to Parliament the design is
part airport entrance part Museum
exhibit to help understand parliamentary
democracy what happens here why it
matters and why it's relevant to
Canadians a massive renovation to bring
the home of Canadian democracy into the
21st century Korea isri Global News
Ottawa
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole team here I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
this beautiful pink sky over sundry
Alberta thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow
[Music]
thank you